cette semaine est ce qu'il est possible
que les québécois non autochtone et
autochtone face ensemble l'indépendance
du québec dans une optique de nation à
nation
oui bienvenue à paroles autochtone 6 et
mélissa cette semaine je vais répondre à
une question de gabriel en disant que
c'est très compliqué parce que par le
passé la discussion de la souveraineté
en interne qui n'a pas souvent été à 200
salles étaient vraiment une présentation
du projet de souveraineté et
malheureusement ils n'excluaient pas les
premières nations dans ce projet
d'ailleurs une des meilleures situations
que je me rappelle que je me rappelle
est un peu si j'étais picard qui disait
que oui on veut la souveraineté mais
pour les premières nations et même le
mot souveraineté c'est très difficile
pour les parents nation parce que ça
veut dire renier sur quelque chose alors
que ce qu'on veut dire d'autre c'est
juste être continuent d'être les
gardiens de nos territoires qu'on garde
dont on est responsable depuis des
milliers d'années
cependant qu'on parle de la souveraineté
du québec tel que le projet s'ouvrait a
été présenté et puis je parle des
premières vagues de souverainistes à une
nouvelle vague aujourd'hui tout ce que
je peux dans font espérer faire passer
le message qu'ils mois malheureusement
dans le plan personnel ont souvent été
mis de l'avant et ça a été un plan ou
est ce qu'on parle d'une souveraineté
basée dans un mythe du bon colonisateur
français et aussi que l'histoire de la
colonisation que soient françaises ou
anglaises ce n'est pas elle n'a pas de
bons colonisateur il n'y a que la
colonisation
cependant le plan de colonisation a été
remplacé par le plan de colonisation
anglais donc on peut parler d'une
expérience partagée par rapport à être
colonisé par la suite j'ai eu des gens
qui m'ont dit raymond refaire la colonie
on va faire la souveraineté
mais on va s'occuper de vous après ça
nous est déjà arrivé on n'aime pas se
faire s'occuper de nous ça donnait les
pensionnaires s'adonner la loi c était
non si on doit parler d'un plan de
souveraineté voudrait qu'on le fasse en
amont aujourd'hui de plus en plus de
gens veulent parler avec des
profanations pour parler de souveraineté
cependant quand on veut parler de
souveraineté si souvent pour dire que on
veut que notre projet passe
donc on va parler avec vous mais il n'y
a pas cette idée qu avant de pouvoir
parler de souveraineté faudrait
permettre aux programmations d'exister
justement dans leur identité dans leur
langue et il ya personne qui pousse les
projets de langue de financement des
projets éducatifs
c'est d'avoir le même les mêmes
avantages que des québécois sur leur
langue et leur identité culturelle pour
les premières nations donc ça se répète
le premier plus pas à faire pour parler
de souveraineté de nation à nation c'est
de dire comment est ce qu'on va
supporter avantages et pousser de
l'avant sauver votre langue de culture
ça serait déjà la première étape avant
de parler de vouloir avoir un pays
ensemble et même là c'est compliqué
parce qu'il faut pas oublier que autant
vous avez des coupes et les provinces à
la verticale nous nos nations sont
naturellement installé à l'horizontale
donc les innus du labrador à l'écrit en
ontario les algonquins les mots à toutes
ces nations là ne sont pas installés
uniquement par province dont l'offre a
aussi pensé de province à province
les enjeux qui touchent les premières
nations et oui c'est possible mais ça
demande d étape naturelle doit venir en
premier et celle de se parler d'eux sans
pré départ des projets de langue de
culture et de repenser l'identité
québécoise aussi avec la réalité
d'aujourd'hui
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de chemin à
faire avant de vouloir aller vers un
plan de souveraineté parfait et une
séparation réaliste pour les
programmations et les québécois alors je
pense que c'est à moi de vous inviter
avant cette discussion là n'hésitez pas
à partager une vidéo n'hésitez pas à
nous envoyer d'autres questions et donne
une des commentaires bonne semaine